la fiscalía de Argentina pidió 12 años
de prisión para la ex presidenta y
actual vicepresidenta del país Cristina
Fernández de kirchner además que se ha
inhabilitada de por vida para ejercer
cargos públicos por los presuntos
delitos de asociación ilícita entre 2007
y 2015 cuando ocupó la casa rosada esta
parte solicita se condene
a Cristina Elizabeth Fernández a la pena
de 12 años de prisión inhabilitación
especial perpetua para ejercer cargos
públicos accesorios legales y el pago de
las costas por considerar la autora
penalmente responsable de los deditos
asocialista agravada por su calidad de
jefa y de administración fraudulenta
agravada por haber sido cometida en
perjuicio de una administración pública
que concurren de manera real la fiscalía
denuncia que se habían desviado mil
millones de dólares al año a través de
más de 50 contratos de obras entregadas
al empresario Lázaro báez condenado a 12
años de cárcel por lavado de dinero
Fernández de 69 años ha defendido su
inocencia y ha denunciado una
persecución política por parte del ente
judicial según ella orquestado por la
oposición de derecha he instruido a mi
abogado para que a los efectos de poder
ejercer Efectivamente mi derecho a
defensa en juicio solicite la ampliación
de mi declaración indagatoria para la
audiencia del día de mañana 23 de agosto
en los últimos años Fernández ha sido
salpicada en varias investigaciones
independientes entre sobornos lavado de
dinero y obstrucción de la justicia en
el reciente procedimiento iniciado en
2019 y que había sido suspendido por la
pandemia del covid 19 no se conocerá una
decisión del tribunal hasta finales de